Ça, tu vois,
ce que tu viens de me dire,
c’est un sujet de dissert,
je pourrais t’en...
je pourrais faire une
dissert de trois heures.
Clem, il dit que c’est un peu de la mauvaise foi
quand je dis que c’est nul,
que je suis nul, etc.,
mais des fois, c’est pas
de la mauvaise foi,
dans le sens où c’est vraiment nul,
ce que j’ai fait.
Moi, je me mets pas mal
pour écrire,
j’essaye d’écrire,
et ça me met mal.
Et puis, de toute façon, qu’est-ce que c’est
des polémiques, maintenant ?
Tu vas avoir 15 articles,
on sait même pas
si les gens les lisent.
- Ce qui est intéressant
dans le doc,
c'est que nous,
d'habitude,
on voit
le "produit fini",
le travail
de ta création.
Là, on voit tout,
c'est-à-dire
tes doutes aussi.
- Ouais.
- Est-ce que
quelque part, le doute,
c'est nécessaire
pour la création,
pour être à l'aise ?
Pour trouver ses idées,
la remise en cause,
elle est obligatoire ?
- Bah je pense que oui.
Pour faire de la
création bien, oui.
Et puis surtout :
quand tu commences
à être à ton quatrième,
cinquième album,
à un moment,
il faut se remettre
en question,
ouais, bien sûr,
parce que
souvent,
on a tendance
à croire que,
genre,
les artistes sont
des génies
qui sortent des trucs
comme ça,
mais peut-être une fois
de temps en temps,
mais la plupart
du temps,
en tout cas, moi,
ce que je fais,
80% est pas bien
et après,
faut faire le tri dedans.
- Et puis t'aimes bien
les trucs nouveaux.
T'aimes bien tester
des trucs nouveaux,
découvrir
des nouveaux univers.
Orel, je l'entends
toujours écouter
des nouvelles musiques.
Tu vois,
il n'écoute jamais
des anciens albums,
enfin pas les siens,
mais même des albums
qu'il a vraiment kiffés.
Tu vois, je sais pas,
un Kendrick Lamar...
Il écoute toujours
des trucs nouveaux,
il a envie d'aller
chercher ailleurs,
trouver des nouvelles
influences :
"Tiens, qu'est-ce
que j'ai pas fait ?"
Donc, par exemple,
au début,
je savais que ça allait
être un truc nouveau,
mais tant que ça existe
pas, tu te dis :
mais qu'est-ce
qu'il va trouver ?
Comment il va faire ?
Quoi.
Ça, c'était assez ouf
à filmer,
à voir, quoi.
- Tu dis que tu écoutes
beaucoup de choses.
C'est quoi
tes influences
dans ton processus
de création ?
Ça dépend, ça change
tout le temps.
Justement,
dans le même album,
je vais avoir cinq
périodes différentes,
et en fonction... Mais
j'écoute quand même
beaucoup
de nouvelles musiques.
Ça veut dire :
ça peut arriver
une fois de temps
en temps
que je me remette
un peu des classiques,
tu vois, je sais pas
des années 1980
ou des classiques
du rap des années 1990,
mais c'est pas du tout
la musique que j'écoute
tous les jours, quoi.
Souvent, j'ai envie...
Je suis curieux,
j'ai envie de connaître
des nouveaux artistes,
de nouveaux courants.
Et forcément,
vu que c'est ça
qui influence
ma musique,
je vais avoir envie de...
ouais, de m'inspirer
de ça, quoi.
C'est quand même
beaucoup d'allers-retours
entre des trucs
du passé
et des trucs du présent,
voire du futur !
- Tu as toujours eu
les Anglais, quoi,
l'Angleterre ?
- Ouais.
- La grime...
Il y a eu des trucs
qui sont restés,
quand même.
- En fait, ça suit
une ligne directrice.
À la base, j'étais
un gros fan de grime.
Maintenant, j'écoute
beaucoup
de drill anglaise,
ce qui est un peu
la continuité du truc.
Mais à un moment,
dans l'album,
j'écoutais
beaucoup d'électro.
À un moment,
c'est un peu...
C'est pas tout à fait
ce que j'ai raconté
juste avant,
mais à un moment,
j'écoutais
les Daft Punk à fond.
À un moment...
Ouais, ça dépend.
Après, il y a toujours
un moment
où je réécoute
du Kendrick.
Il y a toujours
un moment !
Mais j'ai
quand même envie
de faire une musique
un peu différente.
- Et quand
tu les réécoutes, aussi,
je trouve, souvent,
c'est parce
que tu cherches.
C'est aussi, parfois,
c'est marrant,
c'est par plaisir,
mais c'est aussi :
"Ouh,
comment ils ont fait."
Tu vois, aller
chercher leurs secrets.
Toujours prendre
du plaisir,
mais je te voyais
souvent chercher, quoi.
- Ouais, ouais, ouais.
J'écoute plus...
C'est un mélange
de, oui,
aller rechercher,
me dire :
tiens, j'aimais bien
ce morceau,
j'aimerais bien recréer
la vibe de ce morceau.
C'est un mélange de ça,
et après,
tu sais pas pourquoi,
tu allumes la radio...
J'écoute pas mal
les radios anglaises,
genre, je sais pas,
Rinse ou BBC 1Xtra.
Et tu tombes
sur un truc,
tu tombes sur un,
je ne sais pas,
Headie One x Fred again,
et tu te dis :
oh putain,
c'est un nouveau truc.
Et c'est vrai que c'est
un mélange toujours
entre aller chercher
des nouveaux trucs
et des trucs
qui te tombent dessus
par hasard, quoi.
- Perso, moi,
quand je vois le doc,
on ressent par moments
un sentiment
de tristesse,
voire parfois même
de dépression chez toi.
- Ah bon ?!
- Est-ce que tu peux
nous expliquer
les moments parfois
un peu compliqués,
parce que c'est vrai
que dans la créa,
il y a des moments
où tu...
On parlait du doute,
mais il y a aussi
des moments
où ce doute
peut entraîner
des sentiments
parfois négatifs.
Et puis il y a
le confinement aussi.
- Ouais, je sais pas,
Clem, qu'est-ce
que tu en penses ?
Je crois
qu'il est plus...
J'ai besoin d'un
observateur extérieur.
- Comment
tu l'as ressenti, toi ?
C'est des...
C'est plus des
sensations passagères
dont il a besoin,
en fait,
pour aller chercher
des émotions, déjà.
Et puis un petit peu
de mauvaise foi aussi,
parce que quelque part,
je pense,
quand Orel,
il dit
"je ne suis pas fait
pour ça".
Je descends aussi bas
que je suis monté haut.
Putain de merde !
Je trouve tout nul...
Je me suis trompé
de branche,
je chante faux et je sais pas faire de musique.
C'est un peu la facilité.
Tu dis :
"Bon, ben au moins,
c'est normal que
j'aie raté le morceau
que j'ai essayé les deux
dernières semaines,
parce que
de toute façon
je suis pas
fait pour ça."
Mais en fait, après,
tu redeviens
un petit peu lucide,
et puis tu te dis...
tu te dis :
"Non, non, en fait,
vas-y, rebossons."
Mais parce que là,
c'est ce que
j'ai bien aimé filmer,
avec un
tout petit peu de...
Comment dire ?
Ce que j'ai bien
aimé filmer, c'est...
En fait, Orel,
même si
c'est que moi,
on n'est que deux
dans une pièce,
il y a quand même
un petit sentiment
de se jeter
dans le vide
quand il fait
un morceau,
quand il chante,
quand il pousse
la chanson,
tout le monde
qui a fait un karaoké
une fois se sent
complètement con
d'avoir chanté
à tue-tête
du Céline Dion,
alors qu'en fait,
y a rien de grave.
C'est pas très grave,
mais Orel,
y a un peu
ce sentiment-là.
Donc, quand tu t'es mis
un peu à nu,
même si c'est juste face
à moi et à la caméra,
quand c'est pas bien,
après, t'as un peu honte,
t'es pas bien,
tu dis :
"mais pourquoi
j'ai fait ça ?"
- Ouais, c'est
un peu ça, carrément.
Oui, c'est ça.
C'est pas
que, genre, chanter
une chanson
que t'as pas composée,
c'est plus genre
tu réfléchis.
Comment dire ?
Tu vas un peu t'exposer
toi, ta vie,
je vais essayer
de chercher
dans le fin fond
de mes sentiments
pour sortir
un truc intéressant,
et puis...
Et puis...
- Bah, quand c'est
pas bien, tu te dis :
"Mais en fait, je suis
pas intéressant."
- Ouais, ou,
justement...
- Tu vas chercher
au fond de toi,
tu fais un truc,
c'est pas ouf,
tu dis "c'est pas ouf,
ce que je ressens."
- Juste, des fois, aussi,
comment dire ?
En fait, Clem,
il dit
que c'est un peu
de la mauvaise foi
quand je dis
que c'est nul,
que je suis nul, etc.
Y a des fois, ce n'est
pas de la mauvaise foi
dans le sens
où c'est vraiment nul,
ce que j'ai fait,
il n'y a pas de...
Tu vois ce
que je veux dire ?
Les trois premiers... pas
les trois premiers mois,
mais on va dire,
des fois, je vais passer
deux semaines
pour faire un morceau.
Comme
on voit dans le doc,
à un moment,
je fais un morceau,
c'est le premier,
je suis à fond,
je me dis "ça va être
génial", je m'enflamme.
Et quand je me dis
"ça va être génial",
ça veut dire : j'imagine
tout de suite le clip,
j'imagine tout de suite
la tournée.
Il y a sûrement
une part de mon ego
qui imagine le moment
où il va
y avoir un commentaire
où ils vont dire :
"Il a tout compris."
Et en fait, t'écoutes
et t'as rien compris,
et vraiment,
c'est juste pas bien.
Et donc t'as honte,
en fait.
Et le retour
à la réalité,
il est dur, quoi.
- Est-ce que quelque part
on est obligé
de se mettre
un peu mal
dans ses convictions,
dans son talent
pour aller aussi loin
dans le processus
de création ?
- Tu le fais pas pour
écrire, je crois pas.
Enfin, c'est le résultat
quand ce n'est pas
à la hauteur
de tes attentes.
Je crois que tu te mettes
mal pour écrire.
- Ah oui, non, moi,
je me mets pas mal
pour écrire,
j'essaye d'écrire
et ça me met mal.
Ça, c'est sûr.
Moi, si j'ai le choix,
j'aimerais bien,
c'est ce que je dis
aux gars,
à un moment dans
le doc, je leur dis :
"Mais je n'ai pas envie
d'être dans cet état-là,
moi, je veux trouver
la solution."
Et le délire, c'est...
Non, je ne vais pas
puiser mon inspiration
dans la mélancolie,
tel un philosophe
du 19e, tu vois,
que je ne saurai
pas citer !
Tel un poète maudit,
ça, c'est sûr.
Ce que je veux dire,
c'est que je pense,
par contre,
pour en avoir parlé
avec d'autres gens
qui écrivent des trucs,
je pense
qu'à un moment,
si tu veux faire
un bon projet,
il va falloir se remettre
en question,
il va falloir aller
puiser dans
des émotions.
Je prends souvent
cet exemple :
par exemple,
dans la chanson
La Quête qui est genre
une chanson qui a bien
marché de l'album
et qui est une chanson
un peu...
Elle est gentille,
tu vois.
Eh ben, je raconte
quand même des trucs
qui sont des traumas
que j'ai eus, genre,
par exemple,
à un moment, je dis :
"J'abandonne lâchement
tous mes potes",
et tout,
c'est un truc
que j'ai fait
quand j'étais
en quatrième.
♪ Souvent,
j’suis tombé amoureux ♪
♪ Mais pour une fois,
c’est réciproque ♪
♪ J’abandonne lâchement tous mes potes ♪
♪ J’vois plus que ma meuf, on fume des clopes ♪
J'y pense encore
maintenant et, je pense,
il faut se replonger
dans ces émotions
pour aller chercher
un peu des émotions,
justement.
Ton inspiration,
elle vient des émotions,
des moments
que t'as vécus
ou bien c'est un peu :
tiens, j'ai vécu un truc
sur l'instant présent,
là, je pense, ce soir,
il faut que j'écrive.
- C'est le contraire.
Justement,
ça vient plus...
Clem, à un moment,
il a mis dans le doc
un passage où je dis :
"J'ai l'impression
de vivre les émotions
à retardement."
Moi, j'arrive pas
forcément à écrire,
tu vois, genre,
il m'arrive un truc...
J'avais vu une
interview de Bob Dylan
où il disait,
je ne sais pas,
il s'est fait genre...
Il y a
un réceptionniste
qui lui a mal parlé,
il est parti
dans sa chambre,
il a écrit...
un de ses plus
grands pamphlets
qui n'a rien à voir.
"Le Réceptionniste".
Et c'est pour ça aussi
qu'on a pas mal vu
les images du mariage
d'Orel tourner.
Si on les a mises,
c'est parce qu'à
un moment,
ça a à voir
avec la création.
En fait, ça raconte
quelque chose,
et Orel,
il a mis un mois
à le mettre
dans une chanson.
C'est pas le soir même
de ta lune de miel
où tu dis :
"Oui, je vais raconter
ce formidable moment
que je viens de vivre !"
- Il y a des artistes
qui le font très bien,
il y a plein d'artistes
qui sont méga-spontanés,
surtout maintenant dans
la musique actuelle,
ils vont en studio,
ils te sortent
le truc de la journée
et ça défonce
parce qu'ils
ont mis cette vibe,
et même moi,
ça m'est déjà arrivé.
Il y a
des morceaux...
il y a quand même
des morceaux
que j'ai fait en 4 heures
et qui étaient bien.
C'est juste :
je prends ça plus
comme des
exceptions, quoi.
- Quand on parle
de la remise en cause,
des doutes, il y avait
ton producteur
qui disait :
"Dans la musique,
c'est facile de percer,
mais c'est difficile
de rester."
Est-ce que toi,
c'est quelque chose
qui te guide un peu
au quotidien ?
- Ouais, c'est
Ablaye qui dit ça,
il dit : "C'est
facile de percer,
c'est difficile
de rester."
C'est
complètement vrai.
Je pense que souvent
tu vas percer
parce que tu amènes
une fraîcheur
qui est
un peu naturelle,
tu n'as pas besoin
d'aller renouveler
ta musique,
t'as aussi les inspi
du moment
parce que tu amènes
une nouvelle culture,
des nouvelles inspi,
des nouvelles...
une nouvelle vibe
qui est fraîche.
Tandis que
pour rester,
il faut pas faire
la même chose
tout en faisant
un peu les choses
pour lesquelles
on t'aime
et continuer.
Et c'est vraiment vrai
dans la musique,
plus que peut-être
dans la littérature
ou dans le cinéma.
Dans la musique,
il y a beaucoup
d'artistes
qui n'arrivent pas
à le faire longtemps,
parce que c'est dur.
Et même moi,
je me pose
tout le temps
cette question :
si je refais un album
un jour,
je vais avoir...
Ça va être dur.
Je vais me dire
que ça va
peut-être être nul, quoi.
- Tu dis même : "J'ai été
très bien dans ma vie,
pourquoi je refais
un album ?
Je comprends,
Goldman,
pourquoi
il a tout arrêté."
Est-ce que toi,
tu as déjà...
Je reprends.
Est ce que toi,
tu as déjà songé
à tout arrêter ?
Je songe à tout arrêter
à chaque instant.
Même là, par exemple,
je suis en interview,
je me dis :
mais pourquoi
je suis là ?
Ce n'est pas...
Je remets tout
en question
tout le temps,
en fait.
Et en plus,
j'ai plein d'autres
passions, et tout,
ça me dérangerait pas
d'arrêter
sur le moment précis,
mais je sais
que je le regretterais.
- En plus,
c'est trop marrant,
parce qu'il dit ça,
il dit : j'étais très
bien dans ma vie,
pourquoi j'ai voulu ?
Beh, en fait, sa vie,
trois mois avant,
c'était la même chose.
C'était déjà... Tu vois
ce que je veux dire ?
Il s'arrête jamais
de taffer,
donc il dit ça,
sur le moment,
c'est même pas vrai
puisqu'en fait,
avant,
il était en tournée,
et avant...
Il y a quelqu'un,
une fois,
qui lui a posé
la question :
"Mais tu fais quoi
entre tes albums,
en fait, parce que tu
pars longtemps."
Et en fait,
entre ses albums,
Orel, iI tourne,
et puis après,
il refait un autre album.
Y a pas de...
- Voire j'écris
pendant la tournée.
- Ouais, il écrit
pendant la tournée,
il fait mille
autres trucs,
donc même
quand il dit ça
dans la cuisine
à ce moment-là,
en fait,
il se ment à lui-même,
parce que, un an avant,
il était en train de
taffer comme un ouf.
C'est comme là,
je dis
"pourquoi je suis là ?"
alors qu'en fait,
je suis là
parce qu'on a fait
un doc qui est cool
et j'ai envie
que les gens le voient.
Mais il y a quand même
un moment
où t'es face à
tes doutes,
t'es face à... ouais,
t'as envie d'arrêter.
Oui, c'est sûr,
bien sûr,
tous les artistes ont
envie d'arrêter.
Et puis des fois,
t'as juste envie aussi
de changer.
Mais en fait,
la vérité, c'est que
t'as souvent envie
de faire une pause.
- Mais l'envie
d'arrêter ?
Parce que
tu parles de pause,
est-ce que
tu t'es déjà dit :
"Moi, à cet âge-là,
je vais arrêter
ma carrière."
- Ouais, bien sûr.
Je me rappelle, quand
j'avais écrit un texte
sur quand
j'avais 22 ans,
où je disais
"Quand je vois
des artistes
qui ont dépassé
la trentaine,
je suis mort de rire"...
Un truc comme ça.
Dans ma tête,
à 30 ans, t'as...
- Tu te dis quoi
aujourd'hui ?
- Là, qu'est-ce que
je me dis ?
- Qu'est-ce que
que tu lui répondrais ?
- Tu sais quoi ?
Il y a un album
que j'écoutais pas mal
il y a deux ans.
Ça s'appelle...
C'est un artiste
s'appelle Swamp Dogg,
qui a fait un album
assez cool
qui s'appelle Love,
Loss, and Auto-Tune,
un truc comme ça,
il y a un feat
avec Bon Iver,
et genre il a 82 ans,
et genre
il a sorti un album,
que j'écoutais,
qui était frais,
et je me suis dit
"cool", tu vois.
C'est juste...
Par contre,
j'ai pas envie
de refaire tout le temps
la même chose.
Je n'ai pas envie
de m'enfermer
dans un cycle :
album...
album, tournée,
et puis me perdre
là-dedans.
J'ai envie de garder
du plaisir,
j'ai envie de faire
d'autres choses aussi.
- Et dans dix ou
quinze ans, justement,
tu ferais quoi ?
- On verra.
- T'as des idées
un peu en tête,
des projets ?
- Non, justement,
je trouve ça
un peu...
J'ai pas spécialement
envie de me projeter,
Là, j'ai la tournée,
j'ai envie de profiter
de la tournée.
Il me reste encore
une trentaine de dates,
j'ai envie de profiter
de ces dates-là,
d'être genre vraiment
dans le moment,
de faire mes morceaux.
Et puis j'ai envie,
peut-être, ouais,
justement,
d'arrêter de flipper,
déjà, ça pourrait
être bien,
arrêter de me
remettre en question.
- Il est cap aussi
de se mettre,
ou au wing chun,
ou à l'art floral,
ou à...
tu vois ce que je veux
dire, ou aux échecs,
et de se dire :
"Hmm, et si je devenais
professionnel d'échecs",
tu vois !
T'es cap de...
- Mais tu continues
à faire des bons sons.
Je pense.
- Pour tous les deux,
justement,
il y a le doc, l'album,
est-ce qu'il y a des
moments où vous dites :
"Non, je pense que
ni l'un ni l'autre,
ça va le faire."
Est-ce qu'il y a
vraiment eu des doutes
parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de l'album,
mais au niveau du doc,
je pense
qu'il y a des fois
des moments où on
se dit : est-ce que...
Parce que les
conditions de tournage,
ce n'est pas évident,
c'est pendant
le confinement, etc.
- Ouais, c'était
pendant le confinement,
en plus...
Déjà, il y a un truc
hyper relou
pour un documentaire,
c'est les masques.
Parce que tu vois
jamais
les visages des gens,
c'est très relou,
c'est con.
Et moi, en fait,
c'est marrant,
parce que,
donc, moi...
En fait,
c'est pas :
j'ai commencé
à re-tourner
une fois que le doc,
l'année dernière,
est sorti,
je continuais à tourner
pendant que je montais
les épisodes
de la première partie,
et donc
j'étais toujours
un peu dans le tambour
de la machine, quoi.
Et puis...
Et je me suis posé
des questions.
J'étais beaucoup
en miroir
avec mon frère,
en fait.
Orel, il galérait
un peu sur l'album,
moi, je ramenais
des rushes
et j'essayais
de monter
et je galérais aussi
à les monter
pour que ce soit bien,
je me disais : "Mais
est-ce que les gens,
ils ont envie d'entendre,
parler de création,
est-ce que ça va
intéresser les gens ?"
- Est-ce qu'il y a des
trucs vraiment horribles
que t'as coupés,
tu peux nous en parler !
- Des moments
que j'ai coupés.
J'ai failli
couper le moment
où j'essayais
de sauver Orel
en écrivant un couplet.
Si les gars
m'avaient pas dit :
"non, non, c'est bien"...
Les monteurs,
Hugo et Maël,
et Christophe
avec qui j'ai coréalisé,
- Il y a rien d'autre,
promis ?
- Non, qu'est-ce
que j'ai coupé
qui était pas bien ?
Non, un peu comme
dans tout projet,
des trucs trop...
qui ne sont pas
universels, en fait,
trop privés et donc
peu intéressants.
Tout ce qui n'était pas
en lien
avec la création
d'un album.
- Mais toi tu le montes
tout seul ou Orel,
il vient un petit peu
de temps en temps
dire "ouais,
ça j'aime bien,
ça un peu moins."
- Je monte tout seul
et je montrais
à Orel, Ablaye et Skread.
Orel, tu les as vus
deux fois,
les épisodes, je crois.
Moi, même,
il y a encore
un mois...
- J'ai même pas vu
les dernières versions.
- Il me dit : "Mais au
fait, je les ai pas vus,
les épisodes,
et tout, ça y est !"
Il a jamais vu les 4,
les dernières versions.
- Orel, t'as rien fait
retirer, toi.
- C'est pas "retirer".
- Des trucs qui
te semblaient...
"C'est pas cool"...
- Non, je vois
cette question, genre
"qu'est-ce qu'on
montre pas ?",
mais en fait,
moi, les retours
que j'ai, en général,
ils sont vraiment
centrés
sur la narration
et j'ai envie
que ce soit bien,
en fait,
ça veut dire :
il y a des moments,
j'aime pas me voir.
Il y a des moments,
par exemple avec
les petits de Clem,
je vois que je suis
un peu gêné
par leur présence,
ou il y a des moments
où je suis en galère,
où, quand j'appelle
Apple, pour moi,
je suis pas
à mon avantage.
Mais dans l'histoire,
c'est fun.
Donc, au contraire,
je me dis "mettons-les",
et par exemple, j'ai
plus fait des retours
sur
"là on s'ennuie",
ou genre
"ça, je trouve
que ce n'est pas
important",
"peut-être, là,
surtout par rapport
au morceau",
"là, j'aurais peut-être
mis plus de maquettes,
parce que cette maquette
va amener ça."
Mais les retours
que j'ai faits sont
vraiment sur l'histoire,
parce qu'en fait, moi,
je dis,
c'est aussi logique,
je veux dire, plus
les épisodes sont bien,
mieux je vais en sortir.
Peu importe...
- C'est pas la séquence
individuelle
où tu vas briller.
- Ouais, c'est ça.
- Orel, c'est assez
fou d'ailleurs,
parce qu'il arrivait
à voir les épisodes
comme un documentaire
sur, presque,
quelqu'un d'autre.
En fait, il me faisait
des retours
comme si
ce n'était pas lui
qui était à l'écran.
Donc c'étaient
des trucs
pour améliorer
les épisodes.
En vrai, tu les as pas
vus beaucoup de fois,
c'est fou, quoi.
- Les seuls trucs...
Par exemple, tu vois,
il y a mon mariage
dans le doc.
Si Clem,
avant de l'avoir fait,
il m'avait dit "et là,
il y aura ton mariage
dans le doc",
J'aurais dit...
- "Ça va buzzer !"
Ouais, "ça va buzzer."
Ce qui est vraiment
un peu en train
de se passer...
- Pourquoi il est dans
le doc, le mariage ?
Parce que c'est vrai
qu'on voit très peu
ta vie privée,
finalement,
et là,
il y a le mariage.
Donc c'est quoi
l'incidence, finalement,
par rapport à la créa,
à ce que
tu veux montrer ?
- Justement, si
Clem m'avait dit
"il y a le mariage
dans le doc" avant,
je pense que j'aurais
dit non sur le papier,
et il m'a montré
l'épisode fini
avec le mariage,
et il va vous expliquer
pourquoi il l'a mis.
- Et... donc..
Je l'ai mis parce que
c'est en rapport
à la chanson
La Quête
dans laquelle Orel
parle de son mariage.
Il voulait
conclure sa chanson
en trouvant un moment,
justement,
où il se sent bien,
où il n'a pas envie
d'aller chercher
plus loin.
Dans la chanson
La Quête,
il est toujours en train
de chercher
le moment d'après
où il va se sentir bien.
Et en fait,
ce mariage
qui à la base
est un moment
un peu stressant,
en plus qui le coupait
dans l'album et tout,
après l'avoir digéré,
était ce moment
où il se sentait bien
qu'il a utilisé
dans le dernier couplet
de La Quête
pour débloquer
et terminer sa chanson.
Dans la construction
de l'album,
c'était hyper intéressant
et en vrai, on parle
du mariage d'Orel,
il y a dix plans
du mariage,
c'est pas non plus...
On ne voit pas
la préparation
et le choix
des fleurs.
Sinon :
c'est des tulipes.
- Ouais, grave.
Et puis une fois
qu'il m'a montré,
une fois qu'il m'a
montré les images,
je trouvais
que ça faisait
une bonne séquence.
En fait, aussi, en vrai,
finalement,
ma vie privée,
elle est mélangée
avec ma musique.
Je veux dire :
c'est pas de la fiction,
il y a mes vrais
potes dedans.
Donc, au final,
je trouvais que
ça faisait
partie de l'histoire,
de raconter
qu'à un moment,
il y avait aussi
des trucs en famille,
et puis
les images sont cool,
donc j'ai trouvé
que c'était opportun,
peut-être que
je le regretterai.
- Sur ta carrière,
justement,
tu parlais
du cycle
album, tournée
à chaque fois.
C'est un cycle qui est
quand même
très prenant :
La créa. Après,
on s'expose au public.
La tournée aussi.
C'est fatigant.
Est-ce que des fois,
tu n'as pas eu
une sorte de burn out ?
Clairement,
parce qu'on sait que
c'est parfois un terme
un peu tabou
chez les artistes
et que toi, tu t'es dit
"des fois, ouais,
ça m'est arrivé,
j'étais vraiment mal".
Est-ce qu'il y a eu des
moments comme ça ?
- Dans la saison 1
du doc,
on voit qu'après
les polémiques et tout,
je suis un peu...
je suis plus
en requestionnement
et limite,
je dirais pas burn out,
je dirais :
limite mini-déprime.
Mais je m'en suis
rendu compte après.
Et là, burn out,
ouais, ça m'arrive.
Je suis vraiment
pas loin, des fois.
- La batterie
sur le téléphone,
elle commençait
à clignoter.
- Moi, je verrais pas
la batterie
sur le téléphone,
je vois l'aiguille
qui commençait à taper
dans le rouge.
Et des fois,
je dois faire gaffe
parce que je
m'en rapproche.
Je pense que
les burn out,
même dans la vie
de tous les jours,
c'est comme t'es à fond
sur plusieurs projets,
et tout d'un coup,
t'as tous les projets
en même temps.
et ça inclut aussi
ta life,
et à la fin, en vrai,
moi, je vois sur les
images à la fin,
par exemple,
c'est des images
où je me trouve pas
à mon avantage
parce que je suis
vraiment en doute
et je suis vraiment
genre...
faut rendre l'album
et en même temps,
j'ai ma vie privée,
en même temps, j'ai
ma marque de vêtements,
en même temps,
on est en promo
pour le doc.
- Physiquement,
t'étais marqué,
et moi ce que je
raconte dans le doc,
c'est qu'à
un moment,
pendant toute
la phase de création,
c'est assez fun
et marrant,
il y a des moments
plus tendus
que d'autres
et tout, mais...
Mais on s'amuse.
Et même quand
il est en galère,
ça me fait rigoler.
Quand il arrive
vraiment au bout
physiquement
et que tu vois
qu'il a les
joues creusées
et qu'en plus,
par exemple,
on va faire des plateaux
pour vendre le doc,
parce qu'on est contents
de ce qu'on a fait,
et tout, et que
je le vois que...
Qui est pas sa partie
préférée du tout !
Souvent, il est
mal à l'aise, et tout,
et là, là,
je m'inquiète un peu.
Je me dis wow,
là on commence
à tirer sur le physique
et puis sur le
psychologique,
puisqu'évidemment,
t'es fatigué.
T'es plus fragile, quoi.
- Mais toi,
justement,
avec
tout ce succès,
comment tu arrives
à te détacher
un peu de tout ça ?
Voilà, par exemple,
on te voit aussi
faire tes courses.
Ça peut paraître
anodin, mais...
- Il faut que je mange !
- Mais il y en a
plein d'autres
qui pourraient se dire :
"on va les faire
pour moi", etc.
- T'envoies jamais
ton valet.
J'habite en Normandie.
Ouais.
- Et tu te dis...
Est-ce que c'est pas
ces petits gestes
du quotidien
pour rester un peu
dans la vie de M.
et Mme Tout-le-Monde ?
- Moi, je pense,
c'est vraiment
une question
d'entourage,
même par rapport
au burn out.
Je pense que je n'ai
pas vraiment fait
de burn out
parce que j'ai un
entourage solide
avec Skread,
Ablaye, qui sont là,
Clem,
et qu'on se répartit
un peu les tâches
et la pression,
tu vois ?
Je pense que c'est
aussi être conscient,
avoir conscience de
ton statut, un peu.
Par exemple, moi,
faire les courses.
En fait, je veux dire,
je n'ai pas envie
d'être dans le cliché
de la star des années 90
qui a plus de life,
en fait.
Ça veut dire,
moi, pour moi,
c'est plus simple
d'aller faire les courses
quand je dois faire
les courses
qu'appeler quelqu'un
pour faire tes courses.
Enfin, je sais pas,
c'est bizarre.
Donc du coup,
je pense que
ouais, aussi,
quand t'es connu
et tout,
je pense que quand
t'essayes d'être
ce que tu crois
que tu dois être,
c'est là où ça commence
à créer un décalage.
Et moi, en fait,
je vais faire
mes courses,
oui, il y a
des gens qui vont
me prendre
en photo et tout,
mais, déjà, là,
franchement,
99 % des gens sont
archi cool,
c'est un peu
plus long.
Et puis au final,
ouais, je pense,
ouais, mais si, ça aide
quand même
à pas... à pas
devenir ouf, quoi.
- Des fois, devenir ouf,
j'imagine que
c'est parfois aussi
se déconnecter
de Paris.
Moi, je prends
l'exemple,
je suis journaliste,
Paris, Paris,
il y a beaucoup
de boulot ici,
et quand on veut se
ressourcer, des fois,
c'est bien d'aller
dans le petit village...
Voilà, moi, je viens
du nord de la France,
je vais voir
mes parents,
ça détend un peu,
ça éloigne un peu
de cette sphère-là.
Pour toi,
c'est la même chose ?
- Bah ouais,
bah nous,
on vient de Caen,
Orel, il a toujours
représenté Caen
et Alençon aussi,
parce qu'en vrai,
on est arrivés à Caen
au milieu de notre
adolescence, quoi.
Donc c'est des villes,
tu ne peux pas...
Tu viens de
là-bas, quoi.
Tu vois, quand
tu habites à Paris,
tu croises
beaucoup de gens
qui ne sont pas
des Parisiens.
C'est des Rouennais,
des Grenoblois
et des Lillois.
Tu vois, tu...
Tout le monde
reste un peu...
Moi, là, par exemple,
ça fait bientôt dix ans
que j'habite à Paris,
mes enfants,
ils sont nés à Paris,
mais je dis toujours :
bon, dans
deux semaines,
on rentre à Caen,
tu vois ce
que je veux dire ?
Même avec les enfants,
et tout,
tu restes toujours
un peu un petit...
Ça fait du bien.
- Et toi, Orel,
c'est pareil ?
C'est en gros :
Paris, la vie pro,
et Caen,
la vie perso ?
- Moi, dans ma tête,
j'habite plus à Caen
qu'à Paris.
Je suis sur Paris
parce que c'est
là d'où part le tourbus
pour la tournée
et c'est là
où je fais
des interviews, en gros.
Mais la plupart
du temps,
je suis quand même
à Caen.
Après, il n'y a pas
que la situation
géographique.
Par exemple,
pendant l'album,
j'ai coupé
les réseaux.
Même : je gère
différemment
mon rapport à Twitter,
Insta et tout.
Ça veut dire, en gros,
ils sont sur mon iPad
et j'y vais une fois
de temps en temps,
une fois par semaine,
comme je pourrais
regarder une série,
tu vois.
- Tu lis les commentaires
sur les réseaux ?
Je lis les commentaires.
Ça fait longtemps
que je n'ai pas lu
les commentaires,
mais si je les lis
en période
de sortie de projet,
tu vois,
si je sors un clip,
je vais aller voir
peut-être
les deux premières
heures,
ou peut-être
je vais aller...
Si je sors...
Par exemple,
quand le doc,
il va sortir,
je pense, à un moment,
je vais y aller, ouais.
Franchement.
- Comment tu vis ça,
justement ?
Parce que
t'as le processus
où pendant des mois,
tu vas créer,
parfois plus.
Là, ça tombe
dans les mains
du grand public,
avec tout ce que ça a
de bon et moins bon,
parfois, parce que
les réseaux, des fois,
ça peut aussi
être violent, aussi.
- Ouais, ça peut
complètement
être violent,
mais après...
- T'as des commentaires
qui t'ont touché ?
- Ouais, bien sûr.
Mais après, je clique
sur la photo de profil
et je me dis :
mais pourquoi
j'écoute cette personne ?
Si elle venait me voir
dans la vraie vie,
je me dirais juste
"mais non".
Et puis, en fait,
je ne sais pas,
j'ai l'habitude,
c'est juste : moi,
les réseaux,
c'est pas trop
les commentaires
qui me gênent
dans le sens où, déjà,
les gens sont
quand même assez cool
avec moi et tout,
même les mèmes !
Je suis quand même une bonne usine à mèmes !
Et à la rigueur,
c'est pas trop ça.
Non, c'est plus,
en fait,
c'est plus l'info
qui vient des réseaux.
Je veux dire :
même
les commentaires,
des fois, je vais
me poser des questions,
je n'ai pas à
me les poser, en fait.
C'est comme :
j'arrive pas à recevoir
plein d'informations
et juste dire :
ah oui y a ça,
ah oui y a ça...
J'aime bien,
quand je reçois
une information
qui vient d'Insta
ou de n'importe où,
j'aime bien y réfléchir,
me poser.
Ça me touche,
en fait.
Et donc, du coup...
- Je me rappelle,
quand il y a un
des sons qui est sorti,
je sais plus ce que
c'était, t'as lu...
En fait, Orel,
peut-être
L'Odeur de l'essence
par exemple.
Orel commence à lire
les commentaires,
parce que tu le fais,
quoi, un quart d'heure ?
- Ouais.
- Et en fait,
il lit un truc,
c'est : "c'est chan-mé".
Le tweet d'après,
c'est "éclaté".
L'autre tweet :
"c'est de l'électro"
et l'autre va dire
"c'est de la drill".
Et là, Orel,
il fait "OK.
Bon, tout ça,
c'est n'importe quoi,
il y a tous les avis
et tout.
Donc je ferme."
- Oui, c'est ça.
- Il faut faire le tri,
il faut prendre un peu
de recul, quoi.
- En fait, tous
les avis sont exprimés.
Donc en fait,
tu dis : "Wow !"
- Oui, à quel moment
t'as envie
d'avoir tous les avis
de tout le monde
- En même temps !
- En même temps.
Et...
Non, le seul truc,
c'est par exemple :
L'Odeur de l'essence,
je pensais pas que
ça serait un morceau
qui était aussi
politisé que ça, tu vois.
Et ça a vite
pris des ampleurs,
ouais, un peu politiques,
où tout le monde
y mettait un peu
ce qu'il voulait.
Et puis il y a
beaucoup de trucs
avec lesquels
je suis pas d'accord.
C'est-à-dire
je vais lire,
je vais avoir
une réaction un peu,
et après, je vais
devoir me poser
et me dire :
alors pourquoi
je ne suis pas d'accord
avec ce truc ?
Et c'est du temps
de cerveau, quoi.
- Mais notamment
quand tu parles
du côté politique,
tu écris un titre
de sept minutes
avec en fond sonore
des manifestations,
alors moi,
ça m'a parlé parce que
j'en couvre
énormément pour Brut.
Pour la prochaine fois,
je te file même
mes images de manif,
il y a pas de souci.
Mais je me disais,
justement,
est-ce qu'il y a
une fibre derrière ?
Parce que je
me dis :
voilà, on va récupérer
des images,
des sonores
de manifestations,
est-ce que ce qui
est le fond même
de ces manifestations,
ça t'intéresse ?
Les messages portés ?
- Oui. Oui,
ça m'intéresse.
Après,
moi, j'ai du mal à...
Moi, Je me considère
vraiment comme
un artiste.
J'aime bien avoir
tous les points de vue.
Je n'arrive pas à avoir
un point de vue.
C'est pour ça aussi
que je donne
pas forcément...
J'ai des points de vue,
un peu, de base,
tu vois, mais
j'ai vachement de mal
à être certain
d'une idée.
Je vais entendre
un avis,
je vais être d'accord,
Je vais entendre
un autre avis,
je vais être d'accord.
Je vais peser
le pour et le contre
et ça ne m'intéresse
même pas spécialement,
en tout cas dans
mon rôle d'artiste,
d'avoir...
C'est pour ça que ma
chanson sur la manif,
en fait, je prends
différents personnages
parce que j'aimais
bien voir un peu
quelqu'un qui va
être super engagé,
quelqu'un qui est là
parce qu'il a envie
de sortir
avec la personne
super engagée,
quelqu'un qui passe
par hasard
et puis quelqu'un
qui est vraiment
concerné
par le problème.
En fait, le problème,
c'est que souvent,
comme beaucoup
de sujets
de la société actuelle,
c'est des sujets
hyper complexes.
Bien sûr, ça
pourrait m'intéresser.
Il y a plein de sujets
sur lesquels
je me suis penché
pour écrire l'album
ou même...
- C'est quoi les sujets
aujourd'hui
que tu portes
et que t'as envie
de porter à l'avenir ?
Parce que c'est vrai
qu'il y a :
on pense beaucoup
aujourd'hui
à la jeunesse
qui a envie de voir
ses artistes favoris
porter
des sujets importants
sur l'environnement,
sur le féminisme...
D'autres sujets aussi,
sur des sujets
sociaux, aussi.
- Ouais, les sujets,
je pense,
je les porte déjà
dans mes morceaux,
tu vois, c'est juste :
j'essaye
d'amener un peu...
Par exemple,
j'ai galéré
sur l'album
pour faire une chanson
sur l'écologie
parce que j'avais envie
de faire une chanson
sur l'écologie.
Et un peu
comme tout le monde,
je ne me sentais pas
légitime.
Je me sentais...
Je ne savais pas
quoi faire.
J'ai très peu
d'exemples
de chansons écologiques
qui sont cool,
tu vois, je pourrais
peut-être en citer
deux ou trois,
mais c'est souvent
un peu moralisateur.
Et puis je sais pas,
souvent,
la musique,
c'est pour se divertir.
Et donc, finalement,
j'ai fini
par faire une chanson
où, genre,
je suis dans une soirée
où j'ai envie
justement me divertir.
Et finalement,
je commence à un peu
suivre le fil
des choses.
C'est-à-dire :
je suis un gobelet
en plastique,
je vois d'où il vient.
Du coup, ça me nique
ma soirée,
après,
je suis carrément
un vêtement sur toute
la chaîne de production,
un survêt' sur toute
la chaîne de production
et donc pour moi, ça,
c'est ma façon
de m'engager.
- Est-ce que ça pourrait
être aussi
être d'être présent
dans un cortège,
par exemple ?
- Dans un cortège
de manif ?
- Ouais.
Par exemple
d'une manif
pour le climat,
est-ce
qu'on pourrait dire :
un jour, Orelsan,
il va y être ?
- Je sais pas,
pourquoi pas, oui ?
Ce n'est pas vraiment.
Je me suis même pas
posé la question,
parce que pour moi...
pour moi,
oui, c'est bien
d'être présent
dans un cortège,
ça peut être bien,
mais c'est aussi bien
de faire
des chansons, tu vois.
Par exemple,
là, j'ai un projet
en ce moment
à Madagascar où
on a choisi d'essayer
d'aider des artistes.
Dans ma tête,
je vois vraiment
comme ma spécialité,
pour l'instant,
en tout cas,
de ce que je maîtrise,
c'est un peu la musique,
le cinéma, l'écriture.
Donc j'ai envie
d'apporter des choses
par rapport à ça.
Après, le reste,
aller dans une manif.
Tu sais quoi ?
Je me suis jamais posé
la question.
Je ne peux pas
te répondre.
Ça dépend du contexte,
ça dépend d'autres trucs.
- En plus,
tu vois, Orel,
là où, moi,
c'était un exemple
pour moi, c'est :
Moi, je te dis,
il va pas faire
des grands discours
en tant que Aurélien,
il va pas te
dire quoi faire,
il va pas t'expliquer
la vie, par contre,
dans ses chansons,
et ça a beau
être mon grand frère,
c'est aussi
un de mes
rappeurs préférés,
il va me mettre
le doigt sur
des mécanismes
qui vont être
le début de
ma propre réflexion,
que après
je peux me faire
en allant
lire des bouquins,
en parlant à plein
monde et Orel,
pour moi, il a
souvent servi à ça,
à déconstruire
les choses,
à te dire "ah ouais,
tiens, on fait ça,
pourquoi on fait ça ?
C'est normal
qu'on fasse ça ?
Pourquoi est-ce
qu'on ne pourrait pas
faire différemment ?"
Et après, à toi d'aller
chercher tes réponses.
- Tu dis "déconstruire
les choses".
T'as Emmanuel Macron
qui voit en Orelsan
un très bon sociologue
de la société
d'aujourd'hui.
Vous en pensez quoi,
tous les deux ?
- C'est toujours
difficile à répondre
parce que d'un côté,
t’es toujours flatté
quand quelqu'un dit
que ta musique
est bien, et puis
en plus il me dépeint
comme un sociologue,
donc...
Il y a forcément
mon ego à qui ça fait
plaisir, tu vois,
et d'un autre côté...
Et puis aussi parce
que c'est le président,
donc je pense
à mes parents
qui vont dire :
"Le président
de la République
a bien aimé ta musique."
Donc ça fait plaisir.
Après,
d'un autre côté,
tu sais que
dans les médias,
ça va faire
que tout le monde
va interpréter le truc
n'importe comment,
donc même pas envie...
- Toi, ta peur,
c'est la récup politique.
- Ouais,
la récup politique,
et puis aussi, en fait,
c'est des émotions
mélangées.
Je ne peux pas...
Limite, ça,
tu vois, ce que tu
viens de me dire,
c'est un sujet
de dissert.
Je pourrais
faire une dissert
de 3 heures dessus,
mais je n'ai pas envie
d'en parler
en une minute comme ça.
Déjà parce que
je vais regretter,
parce que je pourrais
avoir des arguments
encore mieux que ça.
- C'est un très bon sujet
de bac philo
pour l'année prochaine.
Et puis
ce qui est cool,
c'est de décortiquer,
donc ouais,
tu vois,
un sociologue,
c'est quelqu'un...
c'est un chercheur,
en fait.
Orel, je le vois
comme ça,
comme un chercheur
qui va décortiquer
des choses
presque de manière
un peu statistique,
un peu froide.
Après,
c'est pas pour ça que
tu vas forcément...
- Mais toi,
tu as déjà échangé
avec le président
sur ça ? Non, jamais ?
Non, je connais pas
le président.
Justement, j'essaye
de pas du tout...
De pas du tout...
Moi,
je fais de la musique,
j'essaie
de faire ma musique
le mieux possible,
et après,
justement, aussi,
je trouve que
quand même, un des
problèmes en ce moment,
c'est ce que je dis
dans L'Odeur
de l'essence,
c'est quand même
que tout le monde parle
de tout
et n'importe quoi.
Et moi, je suis
quand même plus...
J'aime bien aussi
avoir un peu de recul
par rapport à ça
pour pouvoir
prendre les émotions,
les remettre
dans la musique.
Et je ne suis pas...
En fait,
je m'y connais pas bien
en politique, tu vois,
et je pense même pas
que mon avis
sur ce sujet, mon avis
sur ce sujet précis,
il est je pense en plus
très compliqué,
je suis même pas sûr
qu'il soit bon.
Donc, je veux dire,
on s'en fout, moi,
je préfère
prendre tout ça,
le mettre un peu
dans un tamis
et sortir
un peu
L'Odeur de l'essence.
Et après
laisser les gens
interpréter,
discuter.
- Après, peut-être que
tu feras la chanson
qui va inspirer
quelqu'un,
où son domaine
où il sera fort,
ce sera la politique.
Exactement !
- Plus loin tu es
des politiques,
mieux c'est pour toi,
vraiment, clairement ?
- Moi, pour l'instant,
en tout cas,
perso,
je n'ai pas...
Ouais, pour l'instant,
perso,
en tout cas,
je n'ai pas de vision...
Ouais, pour
l'instant, ouais,
je me contente
dans mon rôle d'artiste
et j'essaye pas
du tout de faire
de la politique.
Après,
tu me demandes
si je pourrais aller
dans une manif
plus tard.
Je veux dire, je connais
pas le futur,
j'en sais rien.
Justement,
j'exclus rien, en fait.
- Promis, on sort pas
la vidéo si dans 10 ans
tu te présentes président
de la République.
- Ouais, c'est clair !
En mode Kanye.
- Il y a aussi
une question
qui se pose justement
quand on écrit
ces textes aujourd'hui,
on parlait un peu
du rapport
avec les réseaux
sociaux,
est-ce que parfois
on s'autocensure pas ?
Je veux dire, aujourd'hui,
il peut vite
y avoir des polémiques.
Tu vas écrire un texte,
ça va heurter
la sensibilité de telle
ou telle personne.
Est-ce qu'on y pense
avant d'écrire ?
Clem, qui a vu
tout le process,
il va pouvoir
répondre à ça.
Non, je ne pense pas
qu'Orel,
il s'autocensure.
On le montre
dans le doc :
il a des notes
dans son ordi
où il écrit
absolument tout,
mais ça peut même
être des phrases
qui sont pour un futur
personnage
de méchant dans un film,
donc qui va dire
les pires atrocités
de la Terre.
Donc il
s'autorise tout.
Après, est-ce que c'est
le bon moment ?
Est-ce que c'est
la bonne chose à dire ?
En fait, c'est ça
que j'ai essayé
de suivre et de filmer.
C'est à quel moment,
après, tu fais
le tri en disant :
est-ce que c'est bien
dans une chanson ?
Effectivement,
je crois que c'est ça
qui te dirigeait :
est-ce que c'est un truc
que j'ai déjà fait ?
Est-ce que ça vaut
le coup d'être
impertinent
en ce moment ?
Tu vois, le climat
de la création de
l'album,
c'était quand même
Covid, manifs,
Gilets jaunes,
tout ça et tout,
donc est-ce
que j'ai envie
d'être impertinent
à ce moment-là ?
Mais je ne pense
pas que tu penses
à la censure,
à l'autocensure,
à qu'est-ce
qu'on va dire de ça.
- Non...
Ouais,
c'est exactement ça.
Je pense pas à ça.
Je suis juste conscient,
à peu près,
parce que je laisse
quand même des trucs
qui, je sais
que clairement,
mal interprétés,
vont faire
des polémiques.
Mais dans un
cadre que...
- T'as conscience
de quoi ? Des limites ?
Tu te fixes un cadre
en disant :
bon bah,
si je dis ça,
ça peut être...
- Oui, mais
je veux dire, y a pas...
Comment dire ?
Je m'empêche pas
de dire
les choses que j'ai
envie de dire, tu vois.
Et puis de toute façon,
qu'est-ce que c'est,
des polémiques,
maintenant ?
Tu vas avoir
quinze articles,
on sait même pas
si les gens les lisent.
Tu vois.
Je te jure,
il y a des articles,
des fois, je vois, y a
genre deux lecteurs.
- Et comment tu vis,
justement,
à l'ère
de la polémique,
de la petite phrase,
quand on est artiste,
comment toi
tu vis ça ?
Tu le déplores ?
- C'est comme ça.
Il y a pas à
se poser de questions.
C'est comme ça,
en fait.
Et je pense que...
Moi, en plus, j'ai une
méthode de travail
qui fait que, souvent,
je laisse reposer
les choses.
Ça veut dire :
j'ai du recul,
je ne sors pas
des morceaux
du jour au lendemain
sur un coup
de sang, tu vois.
Je ne dis pas
qu'artistiquement,
ce serait pas
intéressant,
c'est juste :
ce n'est pas
comme ça que je fais.
Donc j'ai le temps de
me poser les questions.
Je sais quand même
exactement grosso modo
ce que j'écris, après,
je peux me tromper,
tu vois,
mais je sais comment
ça peut être interprété,
par qui, je vois
à peu près le truc
et après, c'est
un choix d'artiste.
- Tu regrettes,
justement,
cette époque peut-être
qui n'est pas la même
qu'à tes débuts.
Il y a peut-être
plus de liberté
dans les textes,
d'autres vont dire
que c'est mieux parce
qu'on évite de heurter
certaines personnes.
- Mais je ne crois
pas qu'il y avait
plus de liberté
dans les textes, avant.
Je veux dire,
quand Brassens,
il sortait
Gare au gorille,
il avait des galères,
quand Gainsbourg,
il sortait
La Marseillaise
en reggae,
il avait des galères !
Et donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui,
par exemple, tu sors
La Marseillaise
en reggae,
tu es tranquille.
Limite, ils vont
le chanter
aux stades de foot.
Donc je pense que,
justement,
je n'ai pas envie.
C'est pour ça, aussi,
que des fois,
j'ai du mal à parler
de ces sujets-là,
de politique et tout,
parce que j'ai pas envie
de dire qu'on est
dans une époque
pire qu'avant
pour plein de raisons,
notamment
parce que ça va
contribuer
à ce que les gens disent
"on est dans une
époque pire qu'avant",
c'est juste différent.
Et oui,
il y a des sujets
qui vont faire
des polémiques,
des fois c'est mal,
des fois c'est bien.
Il y a aussi
le côté où, genre,
de toute façon,
on peut s'exprimer.
Je veux dire,
si demain il y a
une polémique
sur un de mes textes,
je peux aussi choisir
de l'expliquer.
Souvent, je choisirai
de ne pas faire
attention.
Tu vois ce que
je veux dire ?
Je ne trouve pas
qu'on soit dans
une période non plus...
Dans la période
actuelle, c'est juste...
En fait,
ça dépend aussi.
C'est toi qui te fixes
tes trucs, ça dépend.
Qu'est-ce qu'une
polémique
intéressante
à partir
du moment où...
En fait, moi,
je ne lis pas trop les...
- Parce que souvent,
c'est la petite phrase,
le petit bout de texte.
Ouais, mais c'est parce
que vous,
vous êtes
dans les médias.
Moi, je ne suis pas
dans les médias,
je regarde pas,
ça ne m'intéresse pas.
Donc au final,
pour moi, il n'y a
pas de polémique.
Il y en a eu en plus
des petits trucs
dans l'album et tout.
On va toujours essayer
de chercher.
T'isoles n'importe
quel truc du doc,
ça peut concrètement
faire des polémiques.
Mais vu que je les vois
pas, pour moi
c'est pas des...
Je ne sais
pas comment dire.
Qu'est-ce qui pourrait...
Après,
c'est quoi le risque ?
De perdre du public ?
OK, je sais pas,
franchement,
j'ai pas...
Je ne suis pas
en train de me dire
"on ne peut plus
rien dire", etc.
Parce qu'en fait,
je trouve quand même
que je suis assez libre
dans mes morceaux
et tout, quoi.
- Et dans tes morceaux,
justement,
il y a une anecdote
que j'ai envie
que tu nous racontes,
parce qu'elle
est incroyable.
Un jour,
tu ouvres ton ordinateur.
Moi, ça me parle,
parce que toutes
mes interviews,
je les écris aussi
sur mes notes, aussi,
et là,
il n'y a plus rien.
Et là, c'est dingue.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Est-ce que tu peux
un peu
nous raconter
ce moment-là ?
- Je pense, Clem,
qui arrivait à
ce moment-là,
va mieux le raconter.
- Là où Orel,
il est fort,
c'est qu'il a
une demi-journée
d'hyperactivité
parce qu'on essaie
de les retrouver,
une demi-journée
d'abattement
parce que je dis :
"Wow,
je suis en plein milieu
de mon album,
j'ai tout écrit et
comment je vais faire ?"
Et le lendemain,
en fait,
il fait presque
abstraction du truc,
et il se dit :
"Bon, bah, vas-y,
on va faire autrement,
en fait, tant pis."
Et il y a presque
un truc
un peu de SAS,
il me dit "non, mais
ça ne va pas exister.
En fait, je n'ai
jamais eu de notes.
En fait,
je vais prendre
un crayon,
je vais repartir.
On va repartir
à l'ancienne et tout,
c'est peut-être un
signe", tu vois,
genre, souvent,
y a ce truc-là,
"c'est un signe".
Allez, on y va
et tout,
et en fait,
tu arrives vachement
à aller de l'avant.
Je trouve ça ouf.
- Et Orel,
sur l'instant présent,
comment tu vis
ce moment- là ?
C'est vraiment
un moment, j'y crois...
Au début, je n'y
croyais pas trop.
En fait,
j'ai perdu, genre,
j'ai perdu des tonnes
et des tonnes de notes,
mais quand je dis
des tonnes de notes,
c'est vraiment comme ça
que je travaille
et genre,
Il y avait des idées
de scénarios de film,
il y avait des idées
de dialogues,
il y avait
plein de morceaux,
il y avait plein
de morceaux en cours.
Ça représente
peut-être 10 000
pages de notes,
tu vois.
Et au moment
où je l'ai perdu,
j'avais du mal
à y croire.
Et, en même temps,
il y a une part de moi
qui se dit :
"Tu savais que ça allait
finir par arriver."
Parce que
j'avais un ordi,
je voyais qu'il...
je n'avais jamais.
En fait,
il était tout le temps
en veille et
en fait, en gros,
en fait, un ordi
s'est resynchronisé
dans le cloud
et c'était un ordi
où j'avais très peu
de notes qui s'est
resynchronisé
sur le cloud
où il y avait
toutes mes notes.
Il a, comment
est-ce qu'on dit ?
- Il a écrasé, quoi.
- Il a écrasé, voilà.
Et du coup,
il y a une part de moi
qui dit
"Tu savais que ça allait
finir par arriver."
Il y a un petit moment
de panique.
Le moment dans le doc
où j'appelle Apple,
moi, je vois
que je suis en panique.
Je suis en train
un peu de bégayer.
- Ça se voit pas
tant que ça.
Pas tant que ça.
Peut être si tu connais
pas bien Orel,
ça se voit pas
tant que ça,
mais en fait, ouais,
il est en panique.
Ce qui est fou, c'est
qu'il me laisse filmer,
par contre.
À aucun moment,
même là,
je me suis pas dit :
il va peut-être
me dire
d'éteindre la caméra.
Ça, c'est ouf !
C'est là où Orel,
il est un peu fou.
- C'était tellement...
C'était tellement
gros que, limite,
ça me faisait... Je sais
pas comment dire.
Tu vois, quand
t'es dans des émotions
que tu ne contrôles
pas, et après,
en fait,
limite, en vrai,
j'ai fait
le deuil du truc.
Je me suis dit :
n'y pense même pas,
tu vas pas
les récupérer,
c'est foutu.
- Et là, aujourd'hui,
il y a un backup ?
Tu fais attention ?
- Non, non, non...
Non, j'ai pas changé,
sauf que j'ai plus
cet ordi mal synchro.
Non, c'est vrai, il y a
pas de backup.
J'ai mon pote Mout
qui est là au cas où
pour récupérer
mes notes.
- Une petite question
qui se pose,
Clément, justement,
c'est :
est-ce qu'il y aura
une saison trois ?
- Saison trois,
alors saison trois
peut être dans 10,
15, 20 piges,
peut-être.
- Pas plus tôt ?
- Non, tout de suite...
Là, vraiment,
j'ai plus de rushes,
j'ai plus rien.
En fait, j'avais
des rushes d'avance,
entre guillemets,
parce que j'avais
commencé à filmer
Civilisation
pendant que je montais
les autres épisodes,
mais non, je n'ai
pas continué à filmer.
On est arrivé au bout
d'un truc cool.
Je pense
qu'on a raconté
un truc
comme on voulait
le raconter.
Pour l'instant,
les gens ont bien
adhéré et tout,
donc on était
hyper contents,
et pour l'instant,
il faudrait qu'Orel,
il se relance
dans un énorme projet,
un truc
qu'il a jamais fait
où peut-être
ça me referait kiffer
de le filmer,
mais pour l'instant,
il n'y a pas
de saison trois.
- Ouais, y a pas
- Pas l'année prochaine,
genre "rendez-vous
en octobre".
- On a quand même
un petit sentiment
de boucle bouclée.
En plus, on est
contents
de ce qu'on a fait.
Parce qu'en fait,
en plus,
les quatre épisodes
qu'on a faits là.
Et quand je dis "on",
c'est avec l'équipe,
Christophe Offenstein,
avec qui j'ai
coréalisé,
les monteurs, Hugo,
Maël et toute l'équipe.
- Y a beaucoup
de monde derrière.
- Ouais, c'est ça.
Et en fait, c'était
ce qu'on voulait
faire à la base,
c'était de montrer
comment Orel bosse
et écrit.
Et du coup,
il a fallu les six
épisodes
de l'année dernière
pour qu'on
rencontre Orel,
qu'on le raconte,
qu'on le
connaisse mieux,
connaître Ablaye
et Skread
qui sont les mecs
qui l'entourent,
Phazz, qui est
un musicien avec lui,
et maintenant,
on pouvait rentrer
dans le processus
de création.
Donc en fait,
je suis arrivé
là où je voulais
arriver.
Donc non, il y aura pas
de saison trois.
Ou si vraiment
il y a une saison trois
en octobre 2023
qui sort,
elle sera pas ouf.
Et dites-le moi,
Dites : "Non, non,
la sors pas.
T'avais dit que
tu la sortirais pas !"
Je pense que ce serait
pas une bonne idée
du tout.
- Ça me fait un peu
comme quand
on a fait Bloqués,
parce que Clem,
il écrivait
avec nous sur Bloqués.
Quand on a
fait Bloqués,
on est arrivés
à 120 épisodes,
on a fini le truc,
qu'on s'est dit :
"C'était bien,
le package est là,
n'y touchons plus !
- Signons avec notre sang
de ne jamais réécrire
un épisode.
- Après,
on ne sait jamais
ce qui peut arriver.
Peut-être
on va avoir une idée,
on va se dire : putain,
les mêmes mecs
à 60 piges, qu'est-ce
que ça donne ?
Tu vois ?
Pourquoi pas, mais
en tout cas, Bloqués,
je prends ça
comme exemple
parce qu'on
nous demande
tous les mois
d'en refaire,
tu vois,
dans d'autres contextes,
on parodie
un truc, mais il y a
tellement aussi de...
Comment dire ?
Il y a eu des fois
des reboot,
des remakes,
des suites de séries
dont on était fans
qui au final
auraient bien...
On aurait bien aimé
qu'elles finissent
au bon moment.
Et là, pour l'instant,
pour moi
c'est le bon moment.
Après,
- On sait jamais.
- On ne sait jamais,
oui, si on repart dans
un projet énorme.
- Par exemple, Orel,
c'était un gros fan
de mangas
et on a plein
d'exemples de mangas.
Notre manga préféré,
c'est Slam Dunk.
C'est un manga,
il y a eu, je crois,
34 tomes,
il y en a jamais eu
un de plus.
L'histoire est parfaite,
t'y touches plus.
Tu peux le relire
si tu veux,
tu vas l'apprécier
différemment
au fil du temps.
Mais s'ils refaisaient
des nouveaux épisodes,
je ne sais pas...
En fait, ça dépend.
Il faut que tu aies
la bonne idée,
le bon projet,
la bonne histoire
et que ça ait du sens.
Si tu le fais juste
parce que t'es en galère
et que tu sais
plus quoi faire, ouais,
y a des chances
que ça ne marche pas.
- Et avant
la saison trois,
la deux, que les gens
vont pouvoir
découvrir bientôt,
donc merci
à tous les deux
pour cette interview.
Et puis bonne chance
pour la suite.
- Merci !
- Merci à vous !